welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
special temporary primary host of this
podcast today I'm joined by Greg
Knuckles he is currently the permanent
guest co-host for the time being that of
course is a semi-temporary position that
he's permanently holding for now uh Greg
thank you for joining me thanks for
having me on how you doing today I'm
doing well how are you I'm great we we
are in Peak fall weather right now in
North Carolina where depending on the
day it's like 60 70 degrees Fahrenheit
sunny beautiful I'm loving it uh I am as
well yeah it's good all right uh if you
listen to the show and you enjoy it and
you want to support us there's many ways
you could do that you could like rate or
subscribe wherever you get the podcast
you could join our email newsletter by
going to strongerbuyscience.com
newsletter uh that is not purely a
charitable act on your end it is free
and you basically get uh really nice
emails every now and then giving you
updates about new research about
exercise and nutrition so it's a nice
little newsletter to be part of uh if
you're looking for a one-on-one virtual
coach uh online coaching Services we do
offer that at Stronger by science you
can learn more
you know learn more about our pricing
check out our team of very excellent
coaches by going to
strongerbuyscience.com coaching if you
want to get very affordable supplements
for even better prices you can get those
at bulksupplements.com and use our
discount code the code is SBS pod and
that gets you five percent off your
entire order and then of course if you'd
like to support us even more you could
subscribe to the mass research review
that goes out every single month the
first of the month and it contains a
bunch of very practical very thorough
summaries of the newest research and
exercise and nutrition and of course you
could subscribe to the macro Factor Diet
app which we co-developed which does
have a free trial so you can try it out
and see if you like it before you make
any kind of a financial commitment
um now the big news that everyone's
talking about I've been getting a lot of
mail about this it is officially the
100th episode of The Stronger by science
podcast
um I know what people are thinking Eric
weren't there some other pieces of
content you guys put out yes but that's
not the stronger by science podcast the
100th episode does not include Fireside
Chats
um because we don't really want to
tarnish the brand by incorporating that
uh we got a lot of negative reviews
about those episodes uh it doesn't
include bonus episodes and Live Events
and things like that this is a hundred
episodes of the pure uncut stuff that
everybody loves well I I would say I
would say that it's understandable if
people think that Fireside Chats and the
regular podcasts are the same thing
because yeah sure when you subscribe to
the stronger by science podcast you do
get those other episodes they show up in
the same podcast feed but they they are
different and
I would push back against your
characterization it's more like when uh
you know after someone sells out and
they they do projects like maybe they
make movies with like big budgets for a
big audience or whatever but they still
want to make art on the side they want
to do something for them where it's not
just about the reach and the paycheck
it's about trying to make something
truly great that's what that's what the
Fireside Chats are
um and you know some people don't
appreciate art but that's fine yeah I
don't really get it to be honest
um but anyway so
there's a big question that's been
floating around uh because obviously
everybody's been looking forward to this
100th episode uh people were asking me
Eric is this the first ever Fitness
podcast to reach 100 episodes and
actually the answer is no
um now we were the first podcast and by
default the first Fitness podcast but
then as we know a lot of CopyCat
podcasts kind of popped up iron culture
is one of them there's been a few others
um but they've just been churning out a
bunch of
a bunch of content we'll put it that way
uh really we'll put it that way quite
charitably yeah they've been churning
them out pretty quickly not putting a
whole lot of thought into the quality
you know very much pushing the quantity
side of things so yeah they can put out
several episodes a week uh you know just
really poorly done shoddy work not a lot
of insight not a lot of quality but
we've been curating a premium high level
uh multimedia infotainment experience
with video and screenshots of of you
know figures from studies it's a really
big production here and that takes time
and it takes a lot of effort so it has
taken us a little bit further or a
little bit longer to get to the 100
episode threshold but I'm glad that we
took our time with it and really put
together a great thing no I I agree
wholeheartedly I mean at the end of the
day I'd rather have a hundred Ferraris
than
240 Ford Pintos absolutely for instance
yeah yeah for sure
um now moving on the other thing that's
in the news big thing that's been on
everyone's Minds for about 11.9 months
it's fat bear week it's fat bear week
again so the National Park Service every
year does fat bear week
um do you mind giving us a brief
overview of the the purpose and the
premise yeah yeah so uh I won't talk
about this as much as I did last year
but in short Bears have to get fat for
the winter that's just a fact of life uh
because they hibernate and uh hibernate
this is this is what I went off on a big
tangent about last year but hibernation
it's not all fun and games folks uh I
think people just assume that when bears
hibernate they go in their little Den
they get nice and cozy and either they
they just like peacefully sleep all
winter or uh you know they're just in
there with their family and their little
cubs and they're just having a grand old
time and and it's great well wood
burning stove and it's all cozy yeah
yeah that's not how hibernation is folks
hibernation's [ __ ] terrible uh you so
essentially in animals that hibernate
their body just goes into a low energy
mode uh more or less and so like the
real metabolic adaptation correct some
would say and as part of that
um for reasons I don't entirely
understand they also just like
don't sleep much like it leads to to
Shorter uh sleep periods and so yeah
you're just like
they're just laying there with like
basically insomnia
um and just like gnawing hunger as they
slowly almost starve to death over like
four or five months and it's just a
miserable experience
um not good all around but if they want
that to go as smoothly as possible they
need to get as fat as possible
beforehand so the Cat my National Park
uh takes pictures of uh quite a few of
the Bears that live there both right
after they get out of hibernation to see
their uh svelte post hibernation
physiques and then around this time
which is pretty soon before they're
going to start hibernating so you can
basically see how effectively they've
bulked over the spring and summer and in
Early Autumn months
um and it's very important that the
Bears do that and so as a way to cheer
them on show them the the support you
would like to give them for their
successful bulks uh the the Cat my
National Park team put these pictures of
the Bears on the website so you can see
their before and afters and vote on
which ones got the got the fattest the
most effectively uh and there's a
bracket and it's quite prestigious to
win like it's it's a pretty big deal uh
it it will be the talk of the bear
Community for the fourth coming year
it's also like pretty serious they don't
just do one of those things where they
rotate it and say like okay you won it
last year so we'll give it to a
different bear who's never won it like
there's some some multiple time like
reigning Champions who have a serious
number of banners hanging in their
Rafters oh yeah yeah so
um do we do we want to get into our
picks and like a little bit of
background for some other Bears yeah so
last year I was a big 32 chunk kind of
guy 32 chunk is the technical name but
the super fans say 32 chonk
um and I'm sticking with it you know
like we had a tough year last year no
question really underperformed in the
bracket but I I think this is a good
year for 32 chunk and the reason that I
really like 32 chunk is I I do kind of
I think he's really relatable uh for me
specifically so you know he's kind of
misunderstood they say that he's a
patient bear and that he'll occupy the
same spot for extended periods of time a
lot of people don't know much about bear
meditation practices but 32 chunk is
very clearly a meditating bear that a
lot of folks in the National Park
Service just don't really get that but I
get that I can relate to that big time
they also say despite his fishing skills
he often waits for scraps and leftovers
from other Bears again that that's just
kind of a Buddhist principle of not
being wasteful you know making sure that
everything goes to use so yeah I I think
you can make a strong case that much
like myself 32 chunk is is walking the
noble Eightfold Path and I'm really
proud of him for it and I think he's
going to win yeah so I I think my my
pick might reveal some some of the
temperamental differences between the
two of us so I am once again rolling
with 128 Grazer that's who I picked last
year she didn't pull it out and quite
frankly if I'm being honest as an
objective fan I I think she brought a
better package last year than this year
uh she she certainly had an effective
summer bulk but I don't think it was
quite as extreme so I don't think she's
gonna win but you know you know what
fandom is all about uh as as a boy from
Ohio like you've seen people who've been
supporting the Browns their entire lives
and sometimes it just is what it is but
128 Grazer uh her her description states
that she is in a specially defensive and
assertive bear when she has Cubs or when
defending a prime fishing location she's
not going to be picking over scraps
she's getting the best fish for herself
um she's been known to push other bears
away when they get too close She's Not
Afraid of physical altercations which I
think is very cool especially for a bear
um and uh her disposition allows her and
her Cubs access to some of the best
fishing spots on the river so she's
willing to put her body on the line to
do right by her kids and I I think
that's very commendable
um if you're listening to this and you'd
like to participate in fat bear week uh
here here's a little a little Glimpse
from Vegas if you're if you're trying to
cash in I have no idea if you can bet on
fat bear week I bet there's some
degenerate gambling site based somewhere
in Europe that lets you uh if anyone's
listening to this check out Paddy Power
and see if they have gambling on fat
bear week it really wouldn't surprise me
um but yeah so if you're if you're the
type of person who you know in baseball
you support the Yankees and college
football you support Alabama like you
just want to go with the big brands that
have it that have a good chance of
winning every year
um probably you should be interested in
480 Otis 480 Otis was the champion in
2021 and also 2014 2016 and 2017. I
believe 480 Otis has the most uh fat
bear week championships of any bear and
currently in the in the bracket and
maybe of all time I gotta say once once
again like 128 Grazer I don't think 480
Otis is bringing his best package into
2022 uh certainly got fat I have I have
no doubts that he'll survive the winter
but boy howdy if there are if there are
images archived on this website from
last year check out his 2021 picks he
got so [ __ ] fat in 2021 I don't think
I don't think he's bringing quite the
same level of dedication uh to the
competition this year but you know he
he's a proven winner he's a proven
Champion
um my pick to win it all this year
again I hope he doesn't I'm I'm I hope
128 Grazer pulls it out but just look
into these pictures it's hard to pick
against 151 Walker
um he jeez he cultivated just a
tremendous amount of mass over this
summer
um and and yeah just just based on the
information that's publicly available if
if the voters are fair and objective uh
I I think he probably has the best
chance of winning this year yeah I mean
time will tell what we'll have to see
what happens but it's going to be an
exciting uh you know it'll probably be
down to the wire as it always is it
always is yeah all right uh moving on
Greg you ready for some hard-hitting
scientific content I am awesome well
you're up first what what do you got for
us cool so
um I'm going to step I wouldn't say
fully outside of my Lane but but just
firmly into your lane uh to talk about
something that you have far more
expertise than me about but uh I wrote
an article about it and I realized uh I
think we published it when the podcast
was still on break so uh we haven't
talked about this on the podcast yet
and quite frankly if I'm if I'm being
completely honest with the audience
um I didn't want a segment this week
that I had to do all that much work on
uh last week I my my segment on
inter-individual variability and
training responses I thought that would
be a tight 30. it ran like an hour 45 uh
so I I think I uh maybe over exerted
myself on that segment a little bit
wanted something a little bit easier and
also this week just as a little teaser
I've been working on an article that
will be published I think is the mass
cover story should be should be out on
November 1st about uh the effects of of
range of motion and long muscle length
training on strength and hypertrophy uh
working on that with Milo wolf
um so yeah that's that's been most of my
work this week so I I wanted a podcast
topic that I could just look at content
I've made before and not have to work
that hard so that's that's the level of
commitment you're getting from me this
week I assume Eric's segment will be
fantastic now before we get into it
though so this was an article not on
Stronger by science.com this is on macro
factorapp.com yes one thing macro Factor
related that we I don't think we've
mentioned yet on the podcast is recipe
sharing is that something that we can uh
share with with the good people I think
we can awesome you wanna you wanna tell
a little bit about recipe sharing yeah
you can share recipes now it's very cool
macro Factor yeah so yeah all right go
on
um but yeah no no it's it's awesome uh
if you make a custom food or recipe you
can just tap on it there's a button that
says share it pulls up the same sort of
sharing menu that you would see for any
other app if you wanted to share a link
from anywhere around the web
um so yeah if you're if you and your
partner or a training partner or friend
or whatever are using macro Factory
together one of you makes a recipe one
of you creates a custom food you can
just click share share a link with them
when they click on the link it will
automatically pull that custom food or
recipe up in the app and you can save it
to your own custom Foods or recipes add
it straight to your plate uh works
really well it's very slick
um very good stuff and it doesn't just
send like oh hey here's the macros for
that casserole it actually sends the
entire recipe in a way that can be
changed so like if you had a version of
it and you put sour cream on it and I
didn't you could send the whole thing
over I could remove the sour cream but
you keep everything else intact yeah and
including like steps for how to prepare
the recipe so in instead of basically
just sending over an ingredient list if
you create a recipe and you actually
like make a recipe like hey here's how
you make this dish
um you can save that for yourself and
when you share that recipe with someone
else all of this preparation
instructions how long it takes to
prepare all of that stuff that will also
be ported over because for me that's the
worst part is when I'm putting together
my chickpea and rice dishes as people
say well how long do I microwave the
chickpeas and I'd say uh in 90 seconds
you know and a lot of that gets lost in
the shuffle but yeah for sure but it's
nice to keep that that granular data
yeah I I don't know if people could
prepare most of the meals you make if
they just had the ingredient list I
think so no you really need those
instructions yeah uh but yeah so so
let's get into this
um so uh the article was about and this
segment will be about body composition
both uh how well and how accurately it
can be assessed and uh what you should
or shouldn't do with the information
that you might glean from a body
composition assessment uh the reason I
thought this was an important topic to
discuss to write an article about and
now to talk about on the podcast is it
seems like a lot of people put a lot of
value and weight on the numbers they get
from a body composition assessment
um you know like I see a lot of people
who set goals like you know I want to be
able to walk around at 12 percent year
round or like I want to get below 20
body fat or whatever
um or you know they they put uh a lot of
value on quantifying their body comp
before and after a bulk to try to assess
exactly how much muscle they've gained
over like the prior six months or
whatever
um so so people seem to put a lot of
value in in these numbers they use it to
guide decision making to evaluate how
well a recent diet went or how much or
how well a recent training phase went
um
so I think it's worth
just discussing in Broad terms like
should you do that
um and and the the short answer is no uh
and the long answer is the topic of the
segment so first things first when
talking about body comp
um it's it's first worth asking like
what is actually being measured so Eric
as the actual body comp expert on the
podcast if you wanted to actually
measure human body composition
how would you have to do that that would
technically be done via a post-mortem
dissection yeah and a chemical analysis
of the tissues removed all right so
um which I've never done by the way for
the record yes uh that is good to know
so uh do you know of a way to actually
measure body composition in a living
human subject I do not that's good I
don't either just wanted to make sure I
wasn't sharing lies with people so yeah
if you actually wanted to get your body
comp measured you would have to be
dissected which I assume most people
don't want to do so uh any any way that
you go about trying to assess your body
composition is just going to be an
estimate based on other things so it's
first worth asking just kind of in Broad
terms what is actually being measured
when you have your body composition
assessed and
in what way are those measurements
actually associated with body
composition so
um there are several popular methods
someone might use to go about assessing
their body comp just kind of to go down
a list uh kind of in Old School one like
that used to be considered a yeah not
exactly gold standard but like silver
standard measurement that people used to
use quite a lot back in the 70s and 80s
still exists not quite as popular
anymore is underwater weighing or
hydrostatic Wayne what's actually being
measured there is uh displacement of
water via the the Archimedes principle
like assessing how much you weigh on
land versus how much you weigh
underwater to then estimate how much
water you're displacing once you have an
idea of how much water is being
displaced you roughly know your body's
volume and from there if you know your
body's mass and volume you can estimate
your body's density and since lean mass
tends to be more dense than fat Mass you
can use total body density to estimate
body composition uh the bod pod is is
more or less just an updated version of
underwater weighing it works on very
similar principles
um it's actually measuring changes in
air pressure within a combined chamber
but it's more or less doing the same
thing like you measure your body's
weight you estimate your body's volume
via the bod pod and then it's the same
sort of deal like if you're less dense
it's assumed you have more fat if you're
more dense it's assumed you have more
lean mass
um some other popular methods are skin
fold calipers and ultrasound
so with both of these essentially what
you're doing is you're measuring the
thickness of subcutaneous fat at various
points in the body and then it's just
kind of assumed that if you have more
subcutaneous fat you also just have more
fat elsewhere particularly visceral fat
so you just essentially roughly estimate
total uh body fatness from measurable
subcutaneous fat thicknesses uh probably
the most commonly used method for
assessing body composition and quite
frankly one of the worst if not the
worst is bioelectrical impedance
um which essentially what what happens
there is you make skin contact with
electrodes uh if if you've gone to a gym
a lot of gyms have these little devices
where you just hold the thing out in
front of you and it passes a current
like through your arms uh also a lot of
smart scales have bia technology built
in where there's little electrodes that
you stand on passes that electrical
current through your feet
um
and essentially the more total tissue
you have the more it will impede that
electrical current but in particular fat
impedes the electrical current to a
greater extent than lean mass does so if
the Bia device sees greater total
impedance it just assumes you have more
body fat
fun little story about bioelectrical
impedance well two funny stories yeah um
one of them was that one of my uh
previous professors from undergrad
he drew the Short Straw among the grad
students back when he was in school and
they were trying to see how much they
could fool a Bia device just by messing
with hydration within a single day yeah
and like I said he drew the Short Straw
so they got him more dehydrated than you
would advise in a controlled setting and
measured and then just you know said all
right drink up as many fluids as you
want Gatorade water Etc and just within
the span of it of a day his body fat
percentage reading went from just
absolutely shredded on one side of the
spectrum to like very very very high
body fat percentage like a lifetime's
worth of fat gain or fat loss within a
single day yeah uh another anecdote was
so Greg you remember when we were
teaching at UNC we had the little uh Bia
devices
so when we were learning how to use
those in kind of a big group setting I
had just competed a couple weeks prior
in bodybuilding and this is before this
is like 2013 before I actually like knew
anything about dieting and more
importantly what to do after a diet yeah
so like dude I just ballooned up after
this competition it was at the point
where like you know if I would take off
my socks at the end of the day I could
still see like them imprinted on my legs
like my body was just like a weird like
water balloon you're like lean healthy
active don't actually have any vascular
issues but you sh you still probably
should have been wearing the compressive
socks yeah people wear on airplanes yeah
it's a very strange like temporary
physiological state where you're just
like why do my lower legs look like I
have like severe heart failure right now
I don't know uh probably not a good
thing not recommended but yeah like you
know my body just didn't know what to do
with all all these calories water
retention Etc and but like I had already
gained uh I don't know how many weeks it
was since my show but I already gained
like from my stage weight easily like 15
pounds and I I do the thing do
everything according to instructions
like 5.4 body fat I was like well you
should have seen me 15 pounds ago you
know when I was when I was apparently
two percent body fat and like yeah of
course it was just nonsense but yeah you
got to be you got to be careful with
those things well yeah I mean so
um when when I was teaching that same
class like there was uh like one of the
other outfit instructors
um who who was like in another program
didn't have to take any like body comp
related classes for for his major or
whatever
um you know like when we were learning
about how to use those devices like we
all use them uh had had Bia assess our
body comp and this guy like this guy was
lean like he he had a visible six pack
like wasn't like sub 10 but it was like
comfortably sub 15
uh the Bia device said he was like 27
body fat and he started having like a
small meltdown and identity crisis yeah
and like me and some of the other
ex-fizz kids had to go over to him and
be like look like they're not going to
teach you this in sports management but
like these devices are fake like you
don't you don't need to worry about this
yeah
um but yeah so uh moving on uh there are
several popular methods of assessing
body comp they basically just use body
geometry so there's a formula developed
by the US Navy back in the day uh
they're a simple weight to height ratios
and now they're like fancy high-tech 3D
body scanners and all of these methods
work on the same general principles
where
people people whose bodies have a
particular shape uh the shape of their
body tends to be at least somewhat
indicative of how much fat they're
storing so like in particular if you
have a particularly large waist
circumference relative to how tall you
are or relative to limb circumferences
that's generally indicative of storing
more body fat like that that's the
general principle that that these things
work on
um
and then finally uh there is dexa dual
energy x-ray absorptiometry
um which look like very high-tech
machines because they are
um but essentially what they do is they
pass uh very weak x-rays through your
body and essentially try to assess how
much energy is being absorbed by the
X-ray and the way they convert that to
an actual body comp estimate is is
pretty interesting so your bones will
absorb more energy than any of your
other tissues your lean mass will absorb
less than bone and your fat mass will
absorb uh less than lean mass well and
essentially that will create a little 2D
print out where your bones show up like
in in kind of the unfiltered way bones
are very white lean mass is like a mid
gray and then fat Mass is like a very
very dark gray because it's not
absorbing as much energy essentially the
darker something is the the less energy
it's absorbing
um I know there are some devices now
that will make like very colorful
printouts from that same information but
uh it's the same general principle and
essentially then there's just an
algorithm that counts pixels
um
that
looks to like basically roughly quantify
like how dark or light a particular
pixel is and then sort it to say like oh
that's a bone pixel that's a lean mass
pixel that's a fat Mass pixel
um and that's that's more or less how
dexa assesses body comp so those are the
basic methods like those are I think all
of the popular methods that someone
would use to estimate their body comp
what is actually being measured how
those things relate to body composition
um but it's worth noting as as we've
already like partially touched on that
all of these methods have uh you know
potential confounders that that make
them not just like one-to-one perfect
representations of actual body
composition so like for for example with
hydrostatic Wayne or the bod pod
um like the the formulas that feed into
those just basically assume that
everyone has the same density of their
fat mass and lean mass which we know in
in many cases to be
um
like not a true assumption so like the
the density of the lean mass component
uh can can vary between races I think
the density of the lean mass component
tends to decrease as age increases uh
hydration levels can affect things so
there there are a lot of little things
that can kind of throw off that
relationship between body density and
body composition and there are even some
things that are more uh more practical
rather than theoretical that a lot of
people don't know about if they haven't
been in a lab so like can you exhale all
the way yeah like a major issue with
underwater weighing people say well how
hard can it be measure on land measure
in the water easy enough well you have
to get every bit of air out of your
lungs that you possibly can otherwise
you're altering your underwater weight
and a lot of people freak out and then
even after you exhale you still have
some residual volume in your lungs how
can you measure that well you can't yeah
you just have to make an estimate like I
I forget what the actual value is but
there's like some number where it's like
okay if if someone exhaled all the way
we're just going to assume they still
have this amount of air left in their
lungs do they actually have that precise
amount of air left in their lungs who
knows but we just hope that they do yeah
and with bod pod Greg you walk in with a
beard like that a lot of air that gets
trapped in a beard that's true can be
tough to deal with yes
um
so so yeah like those those are some
things that can affect like bod pod and
underwater Wayne we've already touched
on Bia like basically anything can throw
off the Bia estimate in a bad mood yeah
like I'm sure like if if it's like
Saturn rising or something yeah like
whatever we could probably come up with
a shorter list of things that don't uh
deleteriously affect Bia measurements
um but then for things like uh US Navy
formula weight weight to height ratio 3D
body scanners
um you know like people have differing
Regional fat storage patterns that could
throw those things off like uh
particularly well for all three of those
formulas way circumference is taken into
account if someone just stores a lot
more subcutaneous fat than visceral fat
all of those things are going to
underestimate their body fat percentage
uh and then with dexa
um like you know basic things like
hydration are you adequately fasted
those can throw off dexa estimates but a
big factor is just that you're
extrapolating 3D estimates of body
composition from 2D images and I think
you mentioned this that on average about
40 percent of the pixels will have some
bone in them and since bone is is like
the brightest indicator on a dexa scan
it absorbs the most energy in pixels
with bone in them which again is like 40
of your body
um you just like can't estimate the the
fat or lean mass that is above or below
those bones just because the bones
overpower everything else so
um even though Dex is very high tech
like there there are still some like uh
basic extrapolation issues with deriving
body comp estimates from those 2D scans
yeah that's always the the thing you
tell people and they're stunned because
dexa is expensive and it gives you know
bone density metrics people think you
know oh this has to be ultra precise
there's probably minimal if any
shortcomings then you say yeah well what
we do is we stack up these pixels and
them before we even begin counting we
lose half yeah almost and people are
like holy [ __ ]
for real yeah I mean yeah this once bone
is in the pixel like a pixel can only be
one thing and the bone just gets thrown
away basically for that purpose yeah so
um moving forward uh now that we've
actually talked about what's actually
being measured when you're assessing
body composition uh and we acknowledge
that any any assessment is just an
estimate it's worth asking how accurate
reliable and precise are these estimates
and there is a lot of research that you
could point to on on this
um and in the show notes we'll link a
seven part article series by James
Krieger that that goes into this just
kind of Technology by technology just
citing a lot of research that looks
specifically at the accuracy and
reliability of all of these methods of
assessing body comp I'm not going to go
through all of the research like one by
one for each method because then I'll be
I'll be staring down another 90 minute
segment and quite frankly that would be
boring as [ __ ] but in in Broad terms
um most methods of assessing body
composition work pretty well for groups
so if you you you know recruit 20 people
and
um you know put them through any of
these methods of assessing body
composition and it says that like the
mean body fat percentage for this group
of people was 22 there's a very good
chance that if you then like if the
Declaration of Helsinki didn't exist and
like the Nuremberg code didn't exist if
you could just like kill these people
and dissect them and actually measure
their body composition their actual like
mean body fat percentage would probably
be somewhere between like 19 and 25
percent so like on a group level even
things like Bia do a pretty good job at
estimating average body composition for
a sufficiently large group of people
um
and the same is true for assessing
changes in body composition like if uh
after a 16-week training intervention
it's found that you know body fat
percentage has decreased by five percent
and lean mass has increased by two
percent in a group of people with most
of these methods of assessing body
composition they'd say oh yeah like body
fat percentage decreased by some number
between about three and seven percent
lean mass increased by some number
between about two and four percent like
there there can still be some small
group level errors but they tend to be
like two or three percent at most so
like for research purposes most of these
methods work quite well some of them
work better than others like for example
dexa is just categorically better than
Bia
um but you know for assessing groups of
people they all get the job done the
question is more about
I assume well you know dear listener
it's worth asking yourself this are you
a a person or are you a group of people
if you're a group of people you can you
can just uh skip ahead to Eric's segment
if you're a single person then it's
worth asking like hey does the relative
accuracy of these body comp devices
apply to me uh like what are the sorts
of errors that I can expect when I have
my own personal uh body composition
assessed
and
uh my basic position and what I hope to
convince you of is that for an
individual most of these methods for
assessing body composition are
if not entirely worthless far less
informative than I think people
naturally assume and I think that comes
from essentially conflating group errors
and average errors with like individual
errors so for example if you're looking
at research on say dexa
you will find that the just the mean
error for a dexa assessment of lean mass
or body fat mass or body fat percentage
compared to a gold standard measure
which is usually some some sort of four
compartment model
um the average error is generally like
less than two percent it's generally
like one like between zero and two
percent give or take so like essentially
if the group level average with a four
compartment model is like 18 body fat
dexa might say it's 19 and a half
percent or something like that so some
people look that look at that and say oh
well
dexa overestimates body fat percentage
by one and a half percent so if I get a
dexa done and it says I'm 14 I know to I
know that that means I'm like 15 and a
half percent but boom like it's it's
that precise number if the mean
overestimate is 1.5 percent that means
my personal overestimate will be exactly
1.5 percent add that on Boom good to go
uh or people might look at things like
uh like average absolute error typical
error
um which for dexa for example is like
two and a half three percent uh and
that's that's like a plus or minus so
for example if if there's two people and
dexa overestimates body fat percentage
by two and a half percent for one of
them underestimates by two and a half
percent for the other the average error
is zero percent the average absolute
error is two and a half percent
so it's slightly savvier people will
will look that and be like oh like the
average absolute error two and a half
three percent so if dexa says I'm 15
body fat that means I'm somewhere
between like 12 and 18 body fat which is
a bit of a range like people might
interpret 12 and 18 to be considerably
different but you know that that is
still like a somewhat tight range and
and they look at that and say oh just
plus or minus the average absolute error
um boom good to go uh relatively tight
range
however I think that if you're
you're an individual uh again like if
the average absolute error is
three percent or something there are
going to be errors for individuals that
are smaller than three percent which
therefore means if the average is three
percent there also have to be errors
considerably greater than three percent
uh and so
I think that if you're an individual
it's worth asking what what is the
largest error that I could get from a
particular method of body comp
assessment and if you want to be
slightly more charitable like what is
the magnitude of error that I at least
have like a decent chance of getting you
know like a 20 25 chance of getting an
error of at least this large so
uh to illustrate this point I I made
some synthetic data that like mimics the
accuracy of of dexa very well so like
with dexa the average uh the average
group errors are pretty small like
generally less than two percent the
average absolute errors tend to be like
two and a half three percent so I I made
a pretty little scatter plot that
conforms to those those specifications
where the average uh the average error
between actual body fat percentage and
an estimated body fat percentage is only
half a percent and the average absolute
error is 2.7 percent so if if you're
watching on YouTube you can you can see
the scatter plot here with a nice little
regression Line running through it you
can see it's a nice tight relationship
uh the R value like describing the
strength of the correlation is around
0.9 which again is around what you see
for high quality methods of body comp
assessment like for example dexa and you
might look at this and say like hey you
know if if this is representative of the
accuracy of dexa scans I feel pretty
good about that like it seems to track
pretty well with people's actual body
fat percentage
but now again if you're watching on
YouTube we'll uh we'll throw a a
histogram up here showing the frequency
of
estimation errors of different
magnitudes and so a lot of people are
are going to be getting pretty small
errors like less than one and a half
percent so you know for a non-trivial
amount of people if dexa says like hey
you're 19 body fat you know you might be
20 you might be 18 but like it's it's
going to be pretty close
but then there are also like a pretty
large number of people with errors in
the three to six percent range like
larger but not like way way larger than
the average absolute error where if
you're getting up to six percent that
means Dex is saying you're 20 body fat
anywhere from like 14 to 26 which like
I think you could figure that out pretty
easily without going in for a dexa scan
and then for like a a decent number of
folks like in excess of 10 of
individuals you're gonna get errors
larger than six percent up to about ten
and a half percent which you know one
once you're dealing with individual
errors in excess of ten percent that's
just a roll of the dice that's a random
number generator uh and is is almost
entirely uninformative
um so like that these are the types of
individual errors that that we're
looking at
um when
as when assessing how useful body
composition estimates are for
individuals I
kind of a rough rule of thumb if the
average absolute error like whatever
it's reported to be
there's a a pretty decent chance like
you know like a better than 20 chance
that the actual error that you see
um or that you could get from your body
composition assessment is like twice as
large as that so if you see that uh you
know the average absolute error for
hydrostatic weight like let's say it's
four percent or something like that that
means there's a pretty decent chance
that you could get errors up to about
eight percent even though the largest
possible errors would be even larger
than that so uh just as just to kind of
like ground us here and I'll note that
that this kind of simulation was to
illustrate the sorts of Errors you could
see for assessing body composition at a
single point in time this same principle
applies to assessing changes over time
as well so like if a particular method
of body comp uh analysis says that your
body fat percentage decreased by eight
percent but the average absolute error
tends to be of like a similar magnet
attitude so like that decrease of eight
percent could be anything from like a
decrease of two percent to a decrease of
fourteen percent like it's it's the same
type of range like this is a
generalizable principle
um so like here's here's one little
illustration to
um
just like
Hammer home this point with with uh like
like in illustration that I think will
just like make intuitive sense to people
so uh let's say you recently completed a
diet you started at a body mass of 100
kilograms about 220 pounds and you cut
down to 80 kilograms or about 175 pounds
and you got dexa scans done before and
after your diet and dexa said you went
from 30 body fat to 20 body fat so
ultimately what we're asking here for
like the usefulness of body composition
assessments is like
what can you do with that information
how should you interpret it
um you know can you use that to say that
your diet was relatively successful or
not so if you take those numbers at face
value and just assume that like dexa has
zero error for estimating body
composition uh those numbers would imply
that over the course of the diet you
lost about 14 kilograms of fat mass and
about six kilograms of lean mass
and I would say for most people that's
kind of an ambiguous outcome like that's
certainly a lot of fat to lose your body
fat percentage decreased by 10 percent
but if you're if you're someone who does
resistance training like you probably
worked pretty hard to gain those six
kilos of lean mass in the first place
and that might feel like quite a lot of
lean mass to lose over the course of the
diet so you know that's kind of a mixed
bag
but then let's assume very
optimistically that the individual
errors produced by these dexa scans are
up to about five percent which like
that's an incredibly charitable
assumption so if we look at it through
that lens uh instead of your body fat
percentage decreasing by exactly 10
percent it may have decreased by up to
15 or by only five percent
if it decreased by 15 from say 30 to 15
body fat that would mean that you lost
18 kilos of fat and only two kilos of
lean mass which I think most people
would interpret as a virtually
unqualified success like you preserved
virtually all of your lean mass lost a
ton of fat I think almost anyone would
be very very happy with that outcome uh
but if the if dexa underestimated your
loss of body fat percentage uh and it
only went down by five percent that
would imply that as you lost 20 kilos
you lost 10 kilos of fat in 10 kilos of
lean mass which I think most people who
who are engaging in resistance training
are interested in preserving lean mass
Etc I think most people would interpret
that as like basically a catastrophic
failure so essentially like if if this
scenario played out you lost 20 kilos
dexa said your body fat percentage went
down to 10 percent
even with like a very charitable
assumption about this sort of individual
areas you can get from dexa scans
essentially what it would be telling you
is that the outcome of your diet was
somewhere between unambiguously good and
catastrophically bad which I think you
could figure out without going in for
those dexa scans like that's essentially
like the entire range of body comp
changes you could have seen are
compatible with those dexa scans you got
um
so yeah like it's it's
I I think just far less informative far
less precise produces far larger
individual level errors than I think
most people realize
yeah I mean I've had clients in the past
who uh
have said hey how often do you think I
should get my body comp tested and I Say
Never And they say well there's this
dexa place in town do you think I should
go and I say no uh unless you're really
interested in learning more about your
bone density in which case Sodexo could
be nice for that but yeah there have
been so many instances where I'll I'll
talk with a client and say like
you know best case scenario this scan is
going to tell us what we already knew
worst case scenario it's going to be way
off and we're going to go with what we
already know to be true anyway and just
say wow that was a crappy scan yeah and
and so within that context it's kind of
hard to justify now I I agree
wholeheartedly I I think for most people
most of the time
getting your body compassed like even
via dexa is less informative like tells
you less explicit information about how
a bulk win or how a cut went then just
like seeing how you look in the mirror
assessing how your clothes fit feeling
how you perform in the gym like
uh
I just think those things for most
people most of the time tell you more
about the relative success of a bulk or
a cut than any method of body comp would
be able to for sure uh so
moving on I also want to briefly touch
upon an issue with Bia that I think a
lot of people aren't aware of like so
folks with smart scales that like if you
sand on them for long enough they'll uh
give you an estimate of your body
composition day to day there's this
assumption that I've seen repeated
multiple times like by by a lot of folks
in a lot of contexts that like yeah yeah
like I I understand that each one of
those measurements could have tremendous
error it could be way overestimating or
way underestimating my body fat
percentage but the changes over time
especially if we Trend them out should
be reliably predictive of what is
actually happening happening with my
body composition so you know if uh if
like maybe I'm actually 20 body fat but
my scale says I'm 35 body fat like
there's a huge error ultimately that's
fine because if I get down to 10 my
scale will say that I've gotten down to
25 percent and I know I'm not 25 body
fat but it should accurately reflect
over time that my body fat percentage
decreased by 10 like that's that's like
an assumption that I think a lot of
people have
um
but like that's not a good assumption to
make in a lot of context uh in in part
because of of how Bia actually measures
what's going on so as I mentioned before
essentially what Bia is measuring is the
impedance of electrical currents and
lean mass impedes electrical currents
less than fat mass does but it does
still impede those electrical currents
so if you have simply more tissue even
if your body composition hasn't changed
dexa will think you've gained body fat
uh and if you like if you lose a lot of
tissue again even if your body
composition hasn't changed dexo will now
think you're leaner like that that's
just how those measurements work
um
and so like for example if you had an
astoundingly successful uh like uh
what do people say now gaintain or main
gain
what whatever I don't know it doesn't
matter if if you if you have if you have
a nice lean bulk and let's say
man it went better than you could have
even conceived of like maybe you're a
new lifter and you put on
10 kilos of muscle in your first year of
lifting without your body fat percentage
changing at all you go from like 70
kilos at 15 body fat to 80 kilos at 15
body fat you just put on a ton of muscle
your Bia scale would say you got fatter
like and you simply didn't but now like
your legs are more muscular there is
more tissue that tissue will impede the
electrical current your scale is passing
through your legs to a greater extent
than than they did before training so
like the the issue with Bia or like I
mean there are tons of issues with Bia
but like in underappreciated issue of
Bia is the fact that it is sensitive not
just to changes in body composition but
two changes in total mass
um to to an extent that I think people
just like don't realize so if you're if
you're using like a smart scale to track
changes in body composition over time
the problem is that
the information it's giving you can be
like not just uninformative but like
actively misinformative over time in
some context where like you could be
getting leaner but it says you're
getting fatter it says you're getting
fatter but you're actually getting
leaner because like total tissue mass is
increasing enough so like
even for purposes of like tracking
changes over time trending it out uh
like Bia scales can be like fully and
actively just misinformative over pretty
long time scales
so uh moving on I think that
um
I think that it's worth taking a step
back
and just asking ourselves like why why
you would want to assess body
composition in the first place and I I
wouldn't be surprised if
uh
some percentage of listeners at this
point feel slightly slightly unmoored
and adrift because
you know they've they've had their body
composition assessed multiple times in
the past they they have previously put a
lot of value on those numbers they get
from those assessments and they feel
like well I I was doing this because
it's important like I need to know this
information to know how my pursuit of my
goals is going like you know like how
else am I supposed to know how well my
last bulk went how well my last cut went
um you know maybe I'm trying to lose
body fat to uh be better at whatever
sport I compete in like I need to be
able to measure my body fat percentage
to know if that's going well
um
and I would I would like to push back
against that impulse like I think if we
acknowledge that we really can't know
our body composition all that accurately
or precisely on an individual level
um I don't think we actually lose
anything because I think more often than
not
most people don't actually care about
body composition goals that much they
they just assume sometimes quite
accurately the changes in body
composition should be predictive of or
associated with the actual changes
they're wanting to see
um but but I I would argue that most of
the time you can assess like a more
direct measure for the outcome you're
interested in than body comp would give
you so like for example
if you're an athlete and you want to
maintain muscle mass while losing fat
for the purpose of improving performance
in your sport
um you know you might think well I
should get my body compassest pre and
post off-season training to see if I
actually did that but the thing to keep
in mind is like you're doing it for the
purpose of improving performance in your
sport and generally there are going to
be tests you can do to see am I
performing better in my sport or are
there like proxy measures for
performance in my sport that are just
way more directly informative than body
comp assessments so you know for for
most like team sports Field Sports like
are you faster can you jump higher is
your change of Direction performance
better uh or just like you know like
let's say you're playing basketball like
if you're running scrimmages or pick up
games like are you getting more buckets
are you getting more rebounds like that
tells you how your performance is doing
and also like you could lead yourself
astray by potentially focusing on this
proxy measure for performance body comp
instead of performance itself so for
example like if your training volume is
quite High uh and you're really
attempting to shed body fat you could
just spend an entire off-season under
fueling yourselves for workouts and
practices
um and you know successfully lose the
body fat you are wanting to but wind up
performing worse like
because you weren't actually able to
train for your sport the way you need to
um so yeah like I I would argue that in
most of those contexts like even if your
goal like even if like a sub goal is to
try to change your body composition for
improving performance in your sport
if your performance improves it doesn't
matter quite as much if your body comp
actually changed and it's very likely
your body comp could change but that
could still be counterproductive because
of what you had to do to accomplish
those changes so yeah I would argue that
in a situation like that you're better
off just assessing sport performance and
seeing if that is improving
um another example like
a lot of people who are very interested
in assessing their body comp with with a
high degree of frequency and regularity
are primarily interested in Aesthetics
like they're trying to build muscle lose
fat achieve a certain physique a certain
look uh and so you know they they want
to get dexa scans every six months every
quarter to see how that is going
but I would argue that for those folks
like your goal is Aesthetics like
take progress pictures look at yourself
in the mirror from time to time uh and
like if you look bigger and you look
leaner
um does it really matter if a dexa scan
says you gained two kilos versus three
and a half kilos of lean mass or if you
lost two percent versus four percent
body fat like I I don't like if if your
goal is ultimately an aesthetic goal
like
Aesthetics are about how you look assess
how you look like that's much more
direct feedback about how the pursuit of
your goal is going than a dexa scan will
give you and I think part of that is
also just uh almost a linguistic or
communication issue like people use a
body fat percentage value as a shorthand
way of conveying a particular physique
look like broadly so you know someone
with a cut might say I want to get down
to nine or ten percent body fat and you
can kind of piece together what that
generally means and say okay yeah I know
what you have in mind yeah or they might
say no I want to be bodybuilding
competition ready we got to get down to
five percent the reality is neither of
those of those people actually care what
their true genuine body fat percentage
is
or they shouldn't what what they're
really trying to do is just give a kind
of shorthand summary of here's the kind
of leanness that I have in mind but
ultimately well I mean trying to find a
device to give you that number is not
the goal the goal is to achieve a
particular look and the easiest way to
try to summarize that concisely is by
throwing a number on it just for
communication purposes right like they
they want to look the way that they
believe people look when those people
are at nine percent body fat exactly
whether or not the the look they want to
achieve does actually comport with nine
percent body fat or whether or not they
actually achieve nine percent body fat
it doesn't matter like they're yeah it's
it's the look that they're after yeah
um or just for like one final example
um you know let's say that it's it's not
about sports it's not about Aesthetics
or anything like that you you really are
just trying to to change or improve your
body composition for the goal of health
or graceful aging like you want to lose
some fat to reduce your risk of heart
disease you're trying to build some
muscle or lean mass for you know
graceful aging less risk of like
osteoporosis uh more Independence fewer
issues with activities of daily living
as you get older Etc
like in a situation like that once again
ultimately like changing body comp isn't
the goal improving your health and your
function is the goal so you know
ultimately if like it it doesn't matter
if some method of assessing body comp
says you lost four kilos of fat versus
eight kilos of fat if your blood
pressure is improving your blood lipids
are improving like more direct markers
for like cardiovascular health
you're accomplishing your goal you know
like
um and similarly with like performance
you know
you can you can just assess performance
you know like if you're trying to build
or maintain strength for graceful aging
like
you can you can get on the same machine
at the gym multiple times and like if
you can now use more weight or do more
reps like cool you're accomplishing your
goal like your your musculoskeletal
performance is improving or you're
maintaining it like whatever you're
trying to accomplish
so like the the argument I'm making here
is that very very rarely are changes in
body comp the actual goal someone is
pursuing
um more often than not changes in body
composition are assumed to be and and
often actually are uh assumed to be
associated with the goal someone is
pursuing or predictive of the goal that
someone is pursuing and more often than
not you can assess
something more closely related to the
actual goal you're pursuing with more
accuracy and precision then you can
assess body comp in the first place so
even if we acknowledge that we can't
assess individual level body comp with
a a high or even I would consider an
acceptable degree of accuracy or
Precision we don't actually lose
anything because most of the time that's
not what you actually care about in the
first place so uh yeah just to wrap up
body comp assessments work really well
for groups don't work that well for
individuals
um but that's fine actually yeah so
things people can track obviously track
your body weight uh objective
performance outcomes you know cardio
metabolic depending on what your goal is
there are many things you can track but
even for people who are more physique
focused you can track your body weight
you can you know keep an eye on the
mirror keep you know keep taking
progress pictures limb circumferences
yeah observe how your your clothing fits
I mean like for for physique related
goals like I think that that calipers
are great because I mean all ultimately
the thing that's going to affect the the
visual is assessment of leanness is just
like how little subcutaneous fat you
have like if you don't have much you're
going to look very shredded and calipers
will tell you that yeah so
you know if you
get a Caliper assessment done
whatever body fat number is spat out
when you run those numbers through a
prediction equation doesn't matter but
like you know if your sum of skin folds
has gone down from like 100 millimeters
to like 70 millimeters regardless of
what percent change in body fat that
corresponds with that that is a direct
measure of hey you have less
subcutaneous fat than you had before and
you probably look more shredded yeah I I
was gonna say I think you can go a
really long way if you're like you know
what I accept the content of this
segment but I still really like uh
having some objective quantitative
things I can track I think go a very
long way with a super cheap tape measure
and a cheap pair of calipers and I know
everyone you know like in the exercise
Science World likes to say you basically
have to be a magician to be good at
caliber caliper tests I mean for
research grade purposes sure fine but if
you're just trying to figure you're out
do I have more or less fat over my bicep
than I used to there's YouTube videos
that can teach you the ropes when it
comes to using calipers you can do it
depending on the site maybe yourself
maybe get a friend or someone to do it
for you but just by taking a tape
measure getting a waist measurement
getting limb circumferences getting some
key caliper measurements you can get a
pretty good idea of what is for example
the total size of my bicep looking at
the circumference or I guess my upper
arm and then look at the subcutaneous
fat thickness there's no need to convert
that to a whole body fat percentage that
information tells you exactly what
you're trying to get and you don't have
to stress over you know aiming for these
kind of arbitrary targets like oh no I
I'm doing everything I hope to do but I
wanted to be six percent body fat like I
think keeping your your sights on more
localized measurements is probably ideal
no I I agree and I would also add that
if you're primarily interested in in
assessing body comp for like health
related purposes
like ultimately a waist circumference
measurement or like a waist to height
ratio again not taking a waste to height
ratio and converting that to a body fat
number but just the actual weight to
height ratio number itself that or again
just waste circumference
that that's more predictive of cardio
metabolic Health outcomes than just like
body fat percentages in part because
like as far as health risks go not all
fat is created equal like you can have a
considerable amount of subcutaneous fat
without that having too much of an
impact on cardium anabolic health risks
but like having a lot of visceral fat
not great uh and where's visceral fat
stored in your abdomen around your waist
so you know if if you had two
individuals and you could like perfectly
measure their body fat percentage and
one's 20 body fat with a ton of visceral
fat and one of them's 27 body fat with a
lot of subcutaneous fat and very little
visceral fat like the person at 27 body
fat is probably in in better shape as
far as like health risks go than the
technically leaner person with more
visceral fat but the leaner person with
more visceral fat will probably have a
larger waist circumference whereas the
other person would probably have like
maybe a larger hip circumference or
thigh circumference or something like
that so yeah for for us like a rough
assessment of body comp for health
related purposes just like a away
circumference works great and again like
just take the circumference number you
don't need to worry about converting
that to uh like a rough body fat
percentage number could like that that
doesn't add any additional like useful
or beneficial information cool sounds
good all right you ready to move on yes
sir all right uh so for my segment in
this episode I'm going to be talking
about Fitness related applications of
mindfulness and meditation I'm going to
keep this one pretty brief and pretty
Snappy because For the First Time Ever
you actually went a little bit longer
than you planned to Jesus [ __ ] Christ
I
I really I thought I was a good boy this
time around not quite Jesus but that's
okay yeah I I just I just checked the
time stamp oh no
um all right so diving into it though uh
we previously had a segment called the
road to Enlightenment and that was me uh
kind of sharing my experience as I was
getting into Buddhism and mindfulness
and meditation the only issue is that it
was a fatally flawed segment didn't last
very long and it was promptly canceled
uh the reason being uh as I got deeper
into it I realized it's going to take me
some time to really get the hang of this
and develop anything that would be
reminiscent of not even expertise but
just proficiency right and so I was like
well it's not going to be fun or an
entertaining or informative for me to
just come in every week and say hey I
meditated a few times this past week
seemed to be fine well and if the
segment went too well eventually you'd
find your yourself backed into a corner
where you basically had to flex about
how enlightened you were getting yeah
which seems like it would defeat the
point yeah I mean there's a lot of ways
it could have gone but literally none of
them were good yeah right but the good
thing is we saw that before it went any
of those directions and promptly
canceled it but I knew that eventually
I'd want to return with a more
substantive segment or multiple segments
over you know over the years about
mindfulness and meditation uh basically
when I have something useful to say now
uh in recent months a month or two ago I
did a I wrote an article in the mass
research review about mindfulness and a
few key applications that might be of
interest to Fitness enthusiasts uh so I
wanted to share a little glimpse into
not my personal experience necessarily
with mindfulness and meditation but I
wanted to to actually take a look at
some of the research that's out there
and uh I know what you're thinking how
much research could they there possibly
be you know it seems like there's a lot
of anecdote about this but you might not
have heard too much about you know
actual scientific research I'll be
honest I knew that it was studied in
some areas you know different types of
mindfulness-based interventions and
meditation interventions I fully and
grossly underestimated the sheer
quantity of research pertaining to
mindfulness uh so I found a systematic
review by Goldberg and colleagues
and in the systematic review they found
44 separate
meta-analyzes about mindfulness-based
interventions now that's not 44 separate
studies that's 44 separate meta-analyzes
within that there were 336 randomized
controlled trials with a total
participant pool of over 30 000
participants so like you know we're out
here talking about betaine and you can
find like six relevant studies meanwhile
mindfulness out here you know 30 000
participants cumulative so there is a
really considerable amount of
mindfulness and meditation related
research that is spread across many
different fields investigating many
different clinical outcomes of Interest
so
um what I want to focus on in this
segment is just a few key areas that
Fitness folks might be interested in
specifically training performance sleep
pain management and eating behaviors so
before we get into the Super applied
stuff for dig into specific studies I
want to cover the basics and and of
course I want to address a caveat that
still exists I'm still a novice in the
area of studying mindfulness meditation
and Buddhism uh I no longer claim to be
I no longer put the big secular Buddhism
tag on it uh I I started going to asanga
locally so every week I have a
meditation group where we study Buddhism
and we meditate together so I do
consider myself to be a practicing
Buddhist uh in the Vietnamese Zen
Buddhism tradition and uh you know I
used to always put the secular tag on it
but the deeper I get into this
particular lineage of Buddhism I just
haven't found anything that strains uh
my beliefs or like brings me into a
metaphysical realm where I'm just like
ah it doesn't really make sense so well
is that because the particular School of
Buddhism you subscribe to is inherently
secular it is it is a pretty secular
interpretation of it yeah I mean but you
know I've talked to a lot of folks and
from what I gather again novice not an
expert someone's going to come dunk on
me on the internet I'm sorry from what I
can gather from a lot of different uh
Zen lineages that I've seen it seems
like they do tend to be pretty secular
by default it's not like they're taking
it and saying well let's you know
repackage this and make it more secular
that just seems to be kind of the the
common approach in a lot of different
traditions and lineages of Zen Buddhism
is that uh you know there's uh there's
just not a big focus on the elements of
what we might consider religious in
nature so not a lot of metaphysical
stuff not a lot of dogmatic stuff not a
lot of uh attachment to various rituals
and stuff so yeah it does you know from
from a western perspective you know
growing up it from my perspective it
does seem to be a lot more secular in
nature than I had anticipated or
expected
um but yeah so so I I'm currently uh you
know practicing in the kind of
Vietnamese Zen Buddhism tradition and
really enjoying it but the big caveat
here is you know I'm still a novice I'll
know way more about this stuff in six
months and I'll know way more about it
in six years so I'm just kind of
presenting the evidence here uh to the
best of my ability but first I want to
start out with uh
yeah you're highlighting the quote that
I have there I I'm just curious who that
quotes from it was Rob said so the the
smart-ass quote that I put in the
outline and almost skipped but now I
have to say talking about how I don't
have all the knowledge I'd like to have
and in many years I'll know a lot more
about this stuff than I do now the quote
was you go you go to war with the Army
you have not the Army you might want or
wish you had at a later time and that is
Donald Rumsfeld who has never been
convicted of a war crime uh
yeah we should we should move on before
I get myself in trouble okay so I want
to start with some definitions right so
number one quick description of
mindfulness because a lot of people when
they hear about it it is a term where
they say but what does that mean
mindfulness of of what right because a
lot of times in just common speech we'll
say hey make sure you're you're mindful
of blank so uh a really good basic
definition that goes around a lot
mindfulness is awareness that arises
through paying attention on purpose in
the present moment and non-judgmentally
so a lot of different mindfulness-based
practices involve basically bringing
your attention to the present moment
very intentionally and just kind of
observing your experience without
passing judgment uh just kind of calmly
observing and I I mentioned a lot of
times people say mindfulness of what and
that's a very good question and uh
tiknot Han is a a zen master uh a monk
in the Vietnamese and Buddhist tradition
uh tiknot Han often says mindfulness is
always mindfulness of something so you
might be sitting and doing a mindfulness
exercise and you might be mindful of
your breath focusing on your breath
that's a very common thing in various
types of meditation uh you might be
mindful of what you're eating right so
mindful eating is a common uh
intervention that we see in the
nutrition literature and that's exactly
what it's sounds like it's taking time
to be present during that meal and
really immersing yourself in that that
meal experience and bringing all of your
focus and attention to it
um and so yeah you could be mindfulness
of a lot of different things uh
sometimes they'll they'll do what you
call a body scan meditation where you
lay down and you work through you know
from your feet to your head or vice
versa
and you're just focusing very intently
on my feet what am I what Sensations am
I feeling in my feet currently and you
think about relaxing the muscles in your
feet you work up to your your calves
your thighs you know you kind of work
all the way up and you're being mindful
of a particular part of your body just
observing your Sensations not judging
them you know not trying to force them
to be any specific way it's just simply
paying attention and a lot of times when
you are able to achieve some sense of
mindfulness and you're doing it
intentionally it can bring a sense of
calmness and Clarity and stability to
one's mind uh which brings me to
meditation uh so take not Han often says
that meditation has two components
stopping and looking deeply but but
ultimately it depends on the type of
meditation that you're doing so uh
meditation takes a lot of different
forms it is probably the most common
mindfulness based intervention of many
uh you know so for example some people
consider different types of yo yoga to
be a mindfulness-based Intervention when
done a certain way but but I saw a link
a really nice link from headspace which
is an app I don't know a lot about the
app but they talk about different types
of meditation and so for example there's
guided versus unguided meditation
there's calming versus Insight
Meditation so a lot of times people
think meditation necessarily implies
that you are really focused on
contemplating about some major topic and
you're trying to you know have some kind
of epiphany sometimes there are
meditation practices that are simply
there for calming you know just to kind
of let your mind rest and to calm down
and relax
sometimes you do Insight met focused
meditations where you actually will calm
your mind first just to make sure that
you have you know appropriate levels of
focus and concentration uh and kind of
just bring that stability to your mind
and then you might start to contemplate
on you know something that you would
kind of plan to think about and get some
insight on beforehand so there might be
something big in your life or a big
topic that you want to really think
about and and contemplate about and get
some insight so there are different ways
to do meditation uh some some ones that
come to mind like I said body scan
different types of visualization
um you know reflection uh sometimes
people chant mantras sometimes people do
yoga there are a ton of different types
of meditation but generally many of them
involve calming your mind and then
bringing your attention bringing
mindfulness to some object of meditation
whether it's just calming your mind
focusing on your breath breath focusing
on the sound of a bell or some kind of
calm music there's a lot of different
ways to do it so with that out of the
way the question is what can
mindfulness-based practices or
interventions actually do for fitness
enthusiasts and I'm going to talk about
a few different areas of research and in
the interest of time I'm going to kind
of go pretty superficial high level with
them rather than getting really into
details but I will put a lot of
references to mostly systematic reviews
and meta-analyzes so people can dig a
little bit deeper if they wish to but
the reason this topic came up in Mass
was because there was a new study a new
systematic review on mindfulness and
mental fatigue
now I wanted to cover this because
mindfulness uh you know certainly
interests me uh but also because uh Mike
zordos Dr zordos has written a few
articles over the last few years about
mental fatigue and uh Research indicates
that when people are mentally kind of
acutely fatigued going into a workout it
can negatively affect their resistance
training performance and so what that
means is you know in a laboratory
setting for example they might bring
people in and say hey do these kind of
kind of tricky math problems but do them
quickly and understand that you have to
get them right you know they put a time
pressure they put an accuracy pressure
it's cognitively demanding and they say
do all these math problems as fast as
you can go and when people do that they
get mentally fatigued and that type of
mentally draining exercise when done
with enough volume essentially can carry
over into a training session and
interfere with your performance even
something as simple as looking at a
smartphone between sets I think in in
one of the in one of the studies there
was just enough going on in the phone uh
that that it was enough to kind of
derail people and cause some degree of
acute mental fatigue yeah like like
before the testing session I think like
one group just sat quietly for 30
minutes and then the other group just
like scrolled social media for 30
minutes and uh
yeah people scrolling social media were
fatigued yeah and so yeah that wasn't
between sets but that is something that
came up in the interpretation it's like
it's one of the most common things to do
between sets these days is kind of pop
open your phone and mess around and and
yeah could potentially contribute to
some some acute mental fatigue
um you know other things that they'll do
sometimes in lab settings is like memory
tasks and again the whole idea is to get
your mind uh really riled up get you
thinking about things that are
cognitively demanding and often putting
some kind of pressure with regards to
time or accuracy or just adding
complexity putting a bunch of
information in your head and saying hey
you need to retain this stuff
um so mental fatigue not a good thing
for acute performance and what they're
looking at uh this was a systematic
review by cow and colleagues CAO
probably pronouncing that wrong uh but
they were looking at studies using
mindfulness-based interventions to try
to
facilitate recovery from acute mental
fatigue uh so they were looking at
intervention a variety of different
mindfulness-based interventions uh
comparing it to uh you know you know
some kind of non-mindfulness-based
intervention with some possibility of
inducing acute mental fatigue and
basically figuring trying to figure out
does this mindfulness type exercise
um facilitate you know recovery from
this acute mental fatigue not going to
bore people with the details but I will
pop a couple things up on the screen
here so right now you can look at table
two if you're watching on YouTube just
kind of an overview of the different uh
interventions that were used to induce
mental fatigue in the eight studies that
qualified for this systematic review uh
now and you can of course pause that if
you want to dig into the details I'll
put the the high res stuff up on the
screen and now looking at table three
it's just an overview of the different
mindfulness-based interventions and that
sounds like a vague term but they wanted
to cast a broad enough net so we're
talking about meditation audio
instruction that kind of walks you you
through a mindfulness exercise you know
a lot of stuff like you know guided
meditation things like that those are
the types of interventions going on here
and generally speaking they were pretty
short in duration you know a lot of them
were only 5 10 15 minutes or so
um and results painting with a very
broad brush here given a basic overview
results were generally pretty favorable
indicating that some of these
mindfulness-based interventions did
facilitate recovery from mental fatigue
and in some cases led to improvements in
psychological and physical performance
outcomes and I think you know you if
you're interested in digging deeper of
course there's the mass article there is
the the full text of this article
um you know there are some caveats you
know the benefits likely will depend on
sufficient experience uh intervention
quality duration of intervention and
there can be a lot of variation from
person to person so I don't want to make
it seem like all mindfulness-based
interventions are equivalent in terms of
Effectiveness nor do I want to make it
seem like it's the perfect intervention
for everybody but broadly speaking the
results were pretty favorable and I
think that this does have plenty of face
validity you know so if we look at acute
mental fatigue and say what is the
problem here and a lot of times it's
we're asking our mind to do a lot of
pretty heavy lifting cognitively or
doing some multitasking trying to rush
through things do some cognitive
challenges and kind of keep a lot of
different plates spinning at once yeah
like if you're if you're going to the
gym after work and like you gotta drive
through rush hour traffic and like you
know people honking there's like
accidents on the side of the road like
you it takes a lot of mental effort to
stay to stay like men mentally engaged
and just get to the gym uh safely and so
like it it might make sense to just kind
of like take a second and and take a
quick breather in the parking lot before
you go in yeah and that's what's really
encouraging about the the specific
interventions is that many of them were
only 10 or 15 minutes long and we
probably do like I would imagine uh I
don't we have weird jobs I I don't know
how much we can generalize our
experience to others but like when I
finish work for the day there's usually
a big push to the finish line and almost
always I have like a minute where I'm
like I need to kind of recover like I
just did some mentally challenging stuff
uh I think a lot of people after leaving
from a full work day making the commute
over to the gym uh or chasing the kids
around the house and then you finally
get a moment where you can get out to
the gym uh it's very common to enter the
gym in a mentally fatigued State
um and so for a lot of folks I think
there's a lot of face validity here if
we think about the things that are used
to experimentally induce mental fatigue
you can kind of think well what would be
the opposite of that and it's like okay
focus on a single thing calmly relax
focus on your breathing as you focus on
one thing this is a lot of times people
wonder what is the purpose like you tell
someone on the surface focus on your
breathing it'll make you perform better
and it's like what the hell do you mean
how can that possibly be the case but
what we're talking about here is having
a single-minded focus on something
that's not cognitively demanding or
challenging there's no accuracy pressure
time pressure it's basically giving your
brain a bit of a rest with a calming
exercise and saying by focusing on one
thing the breath which is very easy or
whatever the you know the instruction
video or audio is telling you to focus
on by focusing on one thing with all of
our attention we fight our urge to focus
on 700 things with really frag augmented
attention and we're thinking about what
we did two hours ago at work and what we
have to do tonight when we get home uh
it can be a surprisingly restorative and
restful thing
um now moving on I'm going to hit some
highlights here very briefly uh
mindfulness and sleep
let me just say this anecdotes are
obviously the top form of evidence
I passed out listening to a guided
meditation last night and I slept like a
baby it was incredible
um so sleep research it's hard to do but
generally the consensus is if you're
into fitness sleep probably ought to be
important to you uh you know sleep
restriction especially chronically is
pretty bad for performance seems to be
pretty bad for training adaptations as
well with the limited evidence that we
have
the challenge with sleep though is that
we don't have a lot of control over the
amount that we sleep like you cannot
consciously just say tonight I will get
nine hours of excellent sleep you don't
get to do that yeah all you can really
do is give yourself sleep opportunities
uh and couple that with sleep hygiene
right so what you can say is
because I've been sleeping like [ __ ] I'm
going to spend eight hours in bed
tonight and in the hours leading up to
bed I'm gonna try to practice good sleep
hygiene and do everything I can
behaviorally to set myself up for a high
likelihood of getting high quality sleep
tonight and the reason I bring that up
is because
if you look at the lists of sleep
hygiene guidelines in a variety of
different you know reputable resources
you know foundations that really focus
on sleep research or you know practical
interventions to facilitate people with
Sleep Disorders or sleep issues
um you know when you go to any of these
big organizations or research groups
that have sleep hygiene guidelines
it basically it's going to come in one
of two forms one of them is going to
describe meditation without calling it
meditation they're going to say like hey
you know maybe dim the lights and lay
down or sit down and relax and you know
just try to you know calm yourself and
maybe listen to a guided relaxation uh
thing and they're just calling they're
just saying meditation without calling
it that yeah but most sleep hygiene
guidelines will sleep hygiene guidelines
will just say hey do a meditation
exercise before bed like it's a good way
to kind of calm down wind down and get
yourself in a place where you're really
relaxed and able to sleep really well uh
and I have you ever tried this by the
way yeah so I I was actually about to
cut you off and and interject uh a bit
of advice I was going to give is try to
find a version of of like meditating or
mindfulness practice that that clicks
for you
um so I used to have like my my sleep
these days is great and I'm I'm very uh
grateful about that but back in the day
I used to have some pretty major sleep
issues uh like like borderline insomnia
pretty frequently I just lay in bed
couldn't get my mind to stop racing just
couldn't fall asleep uh when I was in
college
a hypnotist came to the school uh and
and did like a little like hypnotism
show in the auditorium
um I still don't know the extent to
which those are like real or fake like
whether the students that they call up
or like Patsy's I don't know there's a
part of me that wants to believe but
then there's a part of me that's just
like if I was on that stage I don't
think I'd do half the ridiculous [ __ ]
that these people do so who knows I'd
whatever but uh anyway uh on the way out
the door he mentioned like hey oh hey in
the lobby like I'll have a little table
set up
um and if you would like to buy like
guided meditation uh CDs uh you can you
can do that and since I was having sleep
issues like one of them was for sleep
and I was like okay like I'll give this
a shot this sounds awesome uh so I
bought the CD and I tried to listen to
it the first night
and uh got one of the worst experiences
of my life uh because so I'm I'm very
much like a a princess in the P type
individual when it comes to sleeping
like if it's dark and cool and
completely silent or just like white
noise whatever I can sleep just fine but
if there's any like spoken word any sort
of like music anything like that I just
I just can't fall asleep and it just
annoys the [ __ ] out of me so like I had
this CD on and I was thinking like oh
well like maybe this is something
different and it gets like 10 minutes in
and like I was just getting [ __ ]
pissed off it's just like there's some
annoying person in the corner of your
room just talking their mouth off yeah
like would you shut up yeah I was like
I'm trying to sleep shut the [ __ ] up
stop it and like I was getting like
legitimately heated I was like okay
maybe this isn't for me yeah um but yeah
so so to fall asleep now I do my own
silent like uh uh meditation practice
which which is usually like it's it's
not the kind of like meme version of
just like counting sheep but just like
some repetitive task that I find
enjoyable I'll just like imagine myself
doing that yeah um it's typically
shooting free throws like yeah uh
someone is passing the ball back to me
shoot a free throw get a ball shoot a
free throw never taking my my mind's eye
off of the rim uh and that usually puts
me right out yeah and that's a great
example I mean that's mindfulness of
free throw visual visualization right
but it's something that is repetitive
not cognitively demanding not something
that's going to light up all your
neurons you know you want to be looking
at an fmri and be like whoa there's a
bunch of fireworks in the brain right I
mean it's it's just calming repetitive
simple stuff that that isn't uh you know
cognitively challenging in any way uh
and that that's what you get with a lot
of these kind of sleep-oriented guided
mindfulness or meditation exercises is
you know focus on your breath do a body
scan bring your mind to something that's
very simple something that's in the
present moment very very straightforward
um so yeah um obviously you know we
don't just want to say oh hey this sleep
Foundation says it's good that's science
enough for me or you know hey here's an
anecdote I like doing this it's fine
um I will put in the show notes uh two
different meta-analyzes indicating that
uh mindfulness meditation can have
positive effects on sleep parameters
both in patients with insomnia but also
uh in more of just the general
population one was more from like
workplace mindfulness trainings in
people who were not uh who did not have
any kind of clinical sleep disruption uh
so a couple meta meta-analyzes pointing
in the right direction and the workplace
one um you know it did improve their
sleep but there's also improvements in
uh assessed mindfulness which isn't
surprising uh but but there are
improvements in stress anxiety
psychological distress and just overall
well-being so a lot of things that you
kind of see these things go together you
know calming your mind a few times
throughout the day can kind of help you
get re-centered and kind of recapture
some of that mental and emotional
stability throughout the day and then
when you're sleeping better it's a lot
easier to manage stress well manage
anxiety well uh and ultimately feel like
you have a lot better well-being
throughout the day I mean I know for me
personally sleep disruption immediately
you know my anxiety is worse my ability
to cope with strong emotions throughout
the day is worse you know it it really
sets me up for a pretty tough time if
I'm not sleeping well uh moving on uh
mindfulness for pain management this is
one of the areas of mindfulness research
that's pretty active and there's some
pretty solid data in this area I don't
want to belabor the point too much
because we've talked about it on the
show before and on other people's shows
but this the bio psychosocial model of
pain you know back in the day pain the
world was simpler right you have a a
little tiny pain receptor and it's angry
and therefore you have pain and that's
the end of it uh good old Cartesian
dualism yeah that's not really how we do
it anymore biopsychosocial model of pain
is picked up a lot in the in the the
pain research and that's kind of found
its way into the fitness world uh you
know the folks over at barbell medicine
have done a lot of the work of kind of
popularizing those ideas and it's for
the better you know it's good that we
have a more nuanced understanding of
pain within the Fitness World
um now one of the things that I find
really interesting is that uh you know
if you look at some of the peer-reviewed
papers on the biopsychosocial model of
pain many of these papers will posit
that there are four key elements to
consider with a pain experience there's
no susception there's pain there's pain
behaviors and there is suffering so they
actually explain suffering as being
basically a type of emotional response
to perceived pain and they identify that
as a specific kind of independent
component of the pain experience they
also talk about pain behaviors which is
essentially actions that people carry
out in response to perceived pain and
these are things that are influenced by
both subconscious elements but also just
conditioned responses so to some extent
we we are kind of experiencing these
conditioned responses that have kind of
been planted in our minds a little bit
so in the Fitness World now when people
talk about the biopsychosocial model of
pain and how we attract how we approach
pain among lifters people talk a lot
about pain narratives and usually people
are talking that talking about that in
terms of how you discuss pain with a
client or how a person would discuss
pain with their health practitioner so
we talk about setting these pain
narratives of just how pain is framed
because we don't want to plant these
seeds where we are conditioning
responses that exaggerate the pain or
amplify the pain we want to make sure
that we are being really mindful of
these subjective elements of the pain
experience that that can absolutely be
influenced by the way we speak about it
the way we frame it and that emotional
element that suffering element and I
couldn't get over the fact that you know
by explicitly making suffering its own
element uh it's it's kind of no surprise
that mindfulness meditation being
derived from Buddhism has a pretty clear
application there you know the four
noble truths uh often viewed as kind of
the the foundational teaching in
Buddhism uh traditionally it's framed as
being Buddha's uh first teaching after
achieving Enlightenment but it's about
the truth of suffering the cause of
suffering the end of suffering and the
path that frees us from suffering right
so suffering kind of a big deal in what
in build Buddhism which is where we get
mindfulness meditation practices from uh
so I I think there's obviously a pretty
clear uh link there or a clear parallel
where you'd say Okay aside from just
how we speak about injury with a coach
or with a medical professional we can
also think about you know how might
mindfulness meditation allow us to kind
of explore some of these elements of
pain and you know no one is going to go
out there and say hey Pain's all in your
head and if you just become calm enough
it'll go away right well some people do
well they shouldn't I mean the the folks
who uh
learned about the biopsychosocial model
like two weeks ago yeah I think some I
think some of the what's the what's that
saying like no one has more Zeal than a
new convert yeah I I think
I think some folks take it a little bit
too far but yeah like like real
practitioners tend to not do that yeah
yeah so you know I think of course there
are you know when it comes to how we
actually act upon this biopsychosocial
model like I said a lot of it has to do
with how we speak about pain how we
interact with coaches and health
practitioners when we're talking about
pain but also
um you know there is an element here
where we want to dig into these other
elements of pain right so so not just
the you know the no susceptive kind of
biological root of pain but also looking
at the emotional element that we would
call suffering in this case
um looking at some of those conditioned
elements and mindfulness meditation
generally speaking if you were to boil
it down it involves you know basically
calming your mind uh decentering
yourself a little bit and taking an
objective look at the situation whatever
you happen to be contemplating about and
separating you know some of the
perceived elements from the the the true
stuff right so kind of figuring out how
much is my perception distorting the way
I see this experience or feel this
experience and so uh you know I think
there's definitely a clear Avenue where
you would say that mindfulness
meditation exercises might have a
valuable role here where you know the
the object of the mindfulness-based
intervention would be your pain and you
would start to say okay this pain is
real I'm experiencing it but is it
possible that there are some emotional
elements that are kind of amplifying the
pain that I'm feeling is it possible
that fear about the pain is amplifying
the just general dread and anxiety
associated with this pain experience you
can start to unravel uh you know the
kind of biological root of the pain from
some of the emotional elements and
psychological elements and conditioned
elements that are really distorting your
pain experience and in most cases
amplifying it and making it turn into
something that causes a lot of anxiety
and fear that is related to the pain but
not necessarily linked to the pain
directly you know you can separate those
out and a mindfulness type of of
intervention might allow you to address
some of those psychological and
emotional elements and basically remove
some of their power a little bit and
yeah the biological elements will will
persist but it might have a big impact
on the subjective pain experience and
without digging into to you know a ton
of different studies on it what I'll
probably do is just link
some meta-analyzes in the show notes
like I said this literature is
developing pretty substantially here
it's not like one or two little pilot
studies there are some meta-analyzes
that I can absolutely uh Link in the
show notes here but broadly speaking it
does look like a lot of these
mindfulness mindfulness based
interventions are pretty helpful in
reducing self-reported pain levels uh
you know in clinical populations who
have chronic pain so there's
meta-analyzes by Goldberg and colleagues
and by Hilton and colleagues where
they've shown that some of these mindful
mindfulness-based interventions are
effective
um not it's not like it's a magic thing
that's going to immediately turn the
pain off but it can alleviate some of
those subjective pain symptoms uh now
the final thing I want to mention here
uh very briefly mindful eating we've
talked about it on the podcast before so
I'm not going to belabor the point but I
did want to make people aware of a good
resource there's a paper by uh the it
was a single author paper by Nelson and
it provides the best description I've
seen in the peer-reviewed literature
about how you actually do mindful eating
you know because some people are like
okay so what just eat a meal and pay
attention it goes a little deeper than
that but that is kind of broadly what it
is right but it's about really taking
your time with the meal
um savoring the meal uh enjoying the
meal and focusing on the food not in a
way that connotes any type of guilt uh
you know not a deviation from Fitness
driving but it's about really enjoying
the meal and enjoying the food for what
it is and enjoying the fact that you are
having a pleasant eating experience
nourishing your body giving it the the
nutrients it needs so that there's a
great uh paper like I said by Nelson
Linked In the show notes that actually
talks you through what it would look
like to try mindful eating
um
a lot of people say well okay well does
it work and that really comes down to
what you think it's supposed to do so
some people wonder often if mindful
eating induces weight loss
and the evidence there is mixed
um so I'll link a couple uh
meta-analyzes and systematic reviews
again in the show notes uh generally
speaking like I said there's some
evidence indicating some interventions
where mindful mindful eating does
indirectly almost kind of
unintentionally lead to some weight loss
but it's very mixed some studies show no
real impact on weight loss but most
importantly that's really not the goal
you know you don't do a mindful eating
in for a mindful eating intervention and
say all right hopefully everybody loses
20 pounds here that's really not the
point and if weight loss occurs and
sometimes it does it's usually kind of a
side effect it's an indirect thing that
that happens rather than the explicit
outcome that has been sought or that the
major outcome of interest but when we
look at other outcomes so for example
caterman and colleagues uh looked at
mindful uh mindful eating interventions
and they found that it led to reductions
in binge eating and emotional eating and
populations who were engaging in those
behaviors there was another systematic
review by you and colleagues where they
found that mindful eating was associated
with reductions in emotional eating
external eating binge eating weight and
shape concern and there were also
improvements related to self-acceptance
and emotional regulation Again
meta-analysis by Rogers and colleagues
finding a whole bunch of favorable
changes related to eating behaviors
depression anxiety eating attitudes so
generally speaking we see that mindful
eating interventions have a lot of
positive outcomes associated with them
in you know meta-analyzes and systematic
reviews but it's simply not explicitly a
weight loss intervention so
um the the utility there is more on the
psychological and behavioral side of
eating uh and just trying to sort out so
you know sometimes people have some like
borderline pathology eating attitudes
and mindful eating interventions seem to
be quite helpful with alleviating some
of those symptoms
now I want to get into some caveats here
um the very first thing I want to
mention as a caveat is I've talked about
some clinical outcomes here and studies
that have been done in clinical patients
whatever your interest is if you believe
that you have a clinical condition that
may warrant medical intervention or
advice from a medical professional don't
don't avoid seeking that medical care
because you're going to try to do
mindfulness stuff instead this stuff is
not meant to replace modern medicine or
anything like that
um you know if you think you need some
medical attention or if you're on the
fence and you're not sure the best case
scenario is go see a medical
professional who's qualified they'll let
you know what you need and if you see
them and they say you know what you can
you can talk to them about it and say I
was thinking about maybe doing some
mindfulness-based interventions to try
to do this without getting into a really
intense kind of medical intervention and
maybe they'll be supportive of that but
don't use this stuff as a reason to
delay medical care that might very well
be necessary another caveat is obviously
unbiased like I said I consider myself
to be a practicing Buddhist very early
in that process but uh there's no
question that I have bias here which is
frankly why I tried to make sure I was
citing a lot of systematic reviews and
meta-analyzes because of course yeah
anyone with a bias can go say oh look at
this pilot study in nine people looks
pretty good so I wanted to to rely on
papers that utilize systematic
literature searches rather than just
kind of picking you know cherry picking
this study or that study
um now there are some nerds who are
skeptical of the mindfulness literature
and I do think it's important to
highlight that so
um I say nerds in an endearing way
um there there's something called the
framework for open and reproducible uh
research training and they maintain a
running list of psychological
replications and reversals you know it's
basically
uh basically a result of the fact that a
whole bunch of foundational psychology
findings turned out to be unreliable and
could not be replicated or reproduced
and so people have said we need
basically like a database to figure out
of all the pillars of knowledge in our
field which of them actually support
load you know and which ones are just
like Styrofoam pillars that don't
actually do anything yeah
um now on this web page
um they do include uh mindfulness for
mental health uh and and they say most
studies are low quality and use
inconsistent designs there's higher
heterogeneity than other mental health
treatments and their strong reason to
suspect reporting bias now to be clear
there are other elements on this webpage
where there are
aggressive and just really obvious
debunking of some of these theories
that's not the case with mindfulness
here and it is specific to mental health
not all mindfulness outcomes
um basically it's on their list of like
hey there's a reason to be cautious here
like let's keep an eye on this yeah um
so it hasn't been like soundly debunked
but there are credible concerns about
how reliable you know I mentioned
there's a lot of randomized controlled
trials people are saying you know what I
appreciate that there's a lot of rcts
here but I wish that they were generally
designed better and and we suspect that
maybe there's some reporting bias that
might be going on so it's important to
point that out and to acknowledge that
yeah what that suggests to me is that
they're probably or there there's a
pretty good chance that there's a real
effect but that the current research
might overestimate the magnitude of the
effect I think that's a very plausible a
very likely uh way to describe it yeah I
think and you could just you could say
that about many things you know I I
think that's the case of just like
research yeah yeah because generally
nulls are less likely to get published
yeah so usually the flashy findings from
people who it's like their pet Theory
they come out early the effect sizes are
big they come back down to earth they
settle sometimes at zero sometimes above
zero but smaller than the initial
estimates so yeah I think it'll probably
settle above zero for most of these
outcomes but like most things smaller
than the initial biggest estimates of
effect size but I do want to address the
the heterogeneity point there are two
things I want to mention here uh first
of all intervention quality can vary
dramatically obviously just like
anything else like the metaphor that
I've used like if you ask if mindfulness
works that it's kind of to me like
asking if teaching works or if coaching
works yeah like yeah good teachers are
are excellent and really shitty teachers
the effect size there isn't going to be
as big right like yeah some people
aren't as good at coaching at teaching
some people aren't as good at designing
or implementing mindfulness
interventions and and frankly some
people aren't really all that about
receiving mindfulness interventions
right like there are many studies that
happen on college campuses kids need
extra credit and it's like here listen
to this for 15 minutes and then take
this little quiz you know I'm sure there
are some people who are just like yeah
the headphones are on but like am I
really focusing on my breathing am I
really blocking out the fact that I have
a date tonight yeah you're not really
doing mindfulness you're you're doing a
bit of mental math to see the extent to
which the Five Points of extra credit
you're about to get will uh whether
that's gonna bump you up from a c to a b
exactly yeah so like mindfulness
absolutely depends on Intervention
quality and also just in individual's
receptiveness to doing mindfulness like
uh it I do wonder how you force someone
to accept and participate in in like
really engage with a mindfulness audio
tape for example
um another thing that that could
contribute to the heterogeneity and this
is also a really important point is that
uh there's a great review paper I'll put
a figure up here indicating that
mindfulness probably falls on like an
inverted U-shaped curve where having a
deficiency of mindfulness processes is
probably not ideal for well-being uh but
also having an excess of mindfulness
processes also is probably not ideal for
well-being and you kind of want to be in
the middle there I see you're you're
smiling and I have no idea why when I
see excess of mindfulness I just think
about the people who do psychedelics for
the first time and just lose their
[ __ ] mind yeah never to be retrieved
because it does I mean sometimes they
they just spiral in bizarre directions
but it does seem like you know the the
first time they experience like ego
death and get a different and like maybe
broader perspective on things uh
they just like get in their own head to
a dangerous extent and it just like
ruins their life no no there are
definitely people who have like a
psychic uh psychedelic experience and
then just turn their life upside down
and it's like I wish you would have
thought about that a little bit more
beforehand yeah in particularly
Ayahuasca like I've I've never done any
psychedelics myself but like I'd be open
to trying them but like not Ayahuasca
like from talking to people who've done
psychedelics like seems like most people
generally have like pretty good
experiences with like LSD and mushrooms
but
it seems like about a a third of the
white guys who go down to Latin America
and do Ayahuasca for the first time just
go insane uh and I don't want to roll
those dice it's it seems like a see what
one it just seems like a bad time like
I've never heard an Ayahuasca experience
that sounds fun uh and yeah like it it
seems uh very risky for for a lot of
people yeah I don't know much about it
um but yeah so when we talk about this
heterogeneity and effect size you know
the reality is that we not I will never
do marijuana though correct just to be
clear for the purpose of the podcast
psychedelics as we all know gets you
closer to God this is as always a
Christian Family Values podcast yeah uh
not marijuana though that's no that's
the bad stuff right so
because of this kind of inverted
U-shaped curve we should expect that for
some people mindfulness is a really
positive intervention but for others it
could actually be contraindicated right
and so when I talked about mindfulness
processes and whether you have a
deficiency or an excess or kind of in
that optimal middle Zone uh for example
one process brought up in this paper and
I'll put this on the screen as well is
self-observation so if you're someone
who has really low self-awareness at
Baseline uh you know you have a
deficiency of this mindfulness process a
mindfulness intervention might be quite
helpful but if you're someone who is
kind of like you know
constantly observing yourself with a
high level of anxiety or depressive
symptoms or a high level even of like
dissociation the last thing you need is
like hey let's do a really deep
reflective mindfulness exercise and just
ruminate on this even more you know
that's like a pretty common symptom of a
lot of like eating disorders too right
um I I yeah I I think uh or is that like
a different type of self-observation I I
think um what you would probably want to
do I mean not this is not medical advice
but I would assume like you know we
talked about mindfulness for eating
behaviors I think usually the object of
observation there would be the food the
experience of eating it would be mindful
eating not let's do a lot of deep
contemplation about your body yeah right
so yeah it's it's kind of just on where
the mindfulness Focus would be but that
is a situation where I would I would
suggest or anticipate that one version
of mindfulness focusing on mindful
eating could be quite helpful in that
scenario but a very body focused
reflective kind of mindfulness exercise
could backfire in that situation
um another one that comes up here is uh
um exposure right so um there are some
instances where people have really high
experiential avoidance and in many types
of therapy they might actually walk you
through some kind of visualization
exercise almost as a form of like
exposure therapy to start building up
some degree of comfort level within a
safe setting you know with a medical
professional
um but of course uh if you are you know
have a ton of anxiety about a certain
thing and and just like it's a really
really adverse thing when you when you
start to think about it the last thing
you would want to do is some kind of
unguided kind of self-directed exposure
therapy where you're putting yourself
into this like catastrophically uh
deleterious psychological State over and
over and over like that's the type of
thing where if you had some kind of
phobia or or some kind of exposure
related thing like that you know a
self-guided mindfulness approach would
not be ideal you'd want to seek out
probably probably some type of
therapeutic in intervention that's
Guided by a medical professional yeah
but those are just a couple examples in
which you know there are some cases
where being low on that mindfulness
curve you know doing a mindfulness-based
intervention could bump you up into that
optimal range and it'd be a very
positive thing but if you're already
starting with an excess of some of these
mindfulness processes doing more
mindfulness would either be unhelpful or
even in some cases could backfire a
little bit uh and so I think when we
think about the heterogeneity that we
see in this research of course we should
think about the kind of standard
research design and statistical Concepts
but we should also think about this as a
pretty targeted intervention that that
isn't really the right intervention for
all people in all situations uh and then
finally
if you've heard all this and you're
interested in maybe giving it a shot you
want to get started and try some
different types of mindfulness based
interventions or meditation
interventions uh a good question is how
to get started I think it's probably
best in my opinion to start with guided
meditation sessions to kind of show you
the ropes because a lot of times people
just sit there for 10 minutes and say
did I do it right and it's like I don't
know so yeah a guided meditation can be
really helpful and there's a variety of
free and paid apps that have those uh in
addition to websites as well if you're
specifically interested in mindful
eating like I said that paper by Nelson
gives a great description of how to
approach it and how to actually apply it
so I'll link that in the show notes and
then finally
um these mindfulness practices are kind
of an offshoot from Buddhism
um and which of course Buddhism takes a
lot of different forms but if you want
to explore some of the basic Buddhist
foundations in a totally
non-non-religious secular way
I actually think that can be helpful in
some cases like so because I try to do
some mindfulness stuff actually several
years ago before I'd ever thought about
Buddhism and one of the things I
struggled with was it was like okay now
contemplate and I was like
contemplate what and it made a lot more
sense to me when I started to understand
where some of this mindfulness
meditation came from when I learned some
of just the basic kind of foundational
Concepts uh within Buddhism things like
non-self things like aimlessness things
like impermanence some of these basic
foundational ideas it made it a lot
easier to understand oh I I understand
why I'm trying to get away from
ruminating on the past being anxious
about the future getting into the
present moment and kind of experiencing
the present moment in a non-judgmental
way like getting some of those
foundations was a very clarifying
experience for me that made it easier
for me to do
mindfulness interventions that really
had nothing to do with Buddhism so if
you're interested in getting some of
that foundational information I do
recommend Buddhism guide which is a
podcast by Karma yeshi RAB gay it's on
Spotify uh very very good very uh very
approachable very accessible and then
there's just a variety of books by
ticknot Han that I think are excellent
so in conclusion
uh mindfulness is not for everyone uh
like I said there is that kind of
inverted U-shaped curve
um it's not the perfect thing for all
people for all outcomes but there are
evidence-based applications when it
comes to recovery from mental fatigue
sleep enhancement eating Behavior
Improvement pain management and I think
the easiest way to dive in is to find a
nice app or a nice website that has some
some guided mindfulness exercises to
kind of show you the ropes and just to
be clear you don't have to switch
religions to to get into this stuff you
don't have to commit to any kind of
dogmatic beliefs or Embrace any
metaphysical Concepts in order to
participate I think a lot of people
would be surprised to see how
approachable these things are and they
can be as simple as just saying hey take
a few deep breaths calm down and just
give your mind permission to rest uh and
after you do that a few times it becomes
really alarming you start to realize
like I don't think my brain was resting
for like 12 years until I gave this a
shot so uh not for everybody but but you
know it's it can be a helpful thing for
for the outcomes that I mentioned
sounds good man all right anything to
add before we wrap up the 100th episode
um I don't think so nothing nothing's
immediately coming to mind awesome
um well everyone as always thank you so
much for listening uh thank you for
supporting us and allowing us to get
into the triple digits 100 episodes
that's a huge uh a huge milestone to hit
and we couldn't do it without you so
thanks so much for listening and
supporting and we'll be back soon with
another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast if you enjoyed the
podcast be sure to sign up for our free
newsletter to get concise breakdowns of
relevant research as well as 28 free
training programs for all skill levels
and all schedules we hate spam just as
much as you do so we'll only email you
when we have something really
interesting to share with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbyscience.com newsletter or just
go to the stronger by science homepage
and click the free programs button at
the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]